SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. ALVARADO. GIL ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. ATKINS BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
CORTEZ. DALLY DODD. DURAZO
EGGMAN. GLAZER. GONZALEZ GROVE.
HURTADO. JONES LAIRD. LIMON.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. MIN NEWMAN.
NGUYEN. NILO OCHOA. PADILLA.
PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO. SOTO
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
STERN. UMBERG. WAHAB WIENER.
WILK A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
SENATORS. WE WILL BEGIN OUR
SESSION. RIGHT NOW. WE CAN
RETURN TO OUR DESK OR TAKE OUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR WITH
THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS. BE
ON THE ROAD. PLEASE STAND UP.
WE'LL BE LED IN PRAYER TODAY BY
OUR SISTER, MICHELLE GORMAN,
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. AS WE PRAY TODAY,
LET'S CONSIDER. WE MAY BE LIKE
THE LITTLE CRICKET IN MARY
OLIVER'S POEM SONG OF THE
BUILDERS. ON A SUMMER MORNING, I
SAT DOWN ON A HILLSIDE TO THINK
ABOUT GOD. A WORTHY PASTIME NEAR
ME. I SAW A SINGLE CRICKET. IT
WAS MOVING THE GRAINS OF THE
HILLSIDE THIS WAY AND THAT WAY.
HOW GREAT WAS ITS ENERGY, HOW
HUMBLE ITS EFFORT. LET US HOPE
IT WILL ALWAYS BE LIKE THIS.
EACH OF US GOING ON IN OUR
INEXPLICABLE WAYS, BUILDING THE
UNIVERSE, LOVING AND EXPANSIVE
GOD. MAY OUR WORK BE A HYMN OF
GRATITUDE TO THE MYSTERY OF YOUR
PRESENCE AND OUR CREATIVITY AS
WE GO ABOUT OUR ORDINARY WORK IN
EXTRAORDINARY WAYS. WE ASK THIS
IN YOUR NAME, AMEN. PLEASE JOIN
ME IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FIRE
TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS. ONE NATION UNDER GOD,
INDIVISIBLE, WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. SENATORS, I'D
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE A SPECIAL
GUESTS WE HAVE IN THE GALLERY
TODAY. JOINING US TODAY, WE HAVE
GARY HARDY JUNIOR, A BOARD
MEMBER OF THE LYNWOOD UNITED
SCHOOL DISTRICT BOARD OF
EDUCATION. IF WE CAN WELCOME HIM
AND GIVE HIM A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE. WELCOME TO THE STATE
SENATE. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR REDEEMED READ, AND
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WOULD
BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF A
COMMITTEE WOULD BE DEEMED READ,
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A PAUSE BECAUSE
I'M GOING TOO FAST.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, WE'RE GOING
TO JUMP AROUND A LITTLE BIT AND
GO INTO THE CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE UNDER SECOND READING
FILE, WE HAVE ITEMS ONE THROUGH
13. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 1779 1802, 1960,
2943, 3209. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 14 WILL BE DEEMED
READ. WE HAVE THREE ITEMS UNDER
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT. ITEMS
15, 16 AND 17. WE ARE NOT READY.
SO WE'RE GOING TO TAKE ANOTHER
PAUSE.
WE ARE COMING BACK TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. SENATOR GROVE, ARE
YOU PREPARED FOR THE THREE ITEMS
IN FRONT OF US? WE'RE GOING TO
START OFF WITH MADAM PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU. SENATOR. SECRETARY
SENATOR GROVE, YOU MAY BEGIN ON
FILE ITEM 15. SENATORS, WE ARE
WE ARE BACK. WE ARE BACK LIVE,
SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, THE FILE
ITEM 15 IS A CONFIRMATION OF
SARAH BROOKS FOR APPOINTMENT TO
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF HEALTH
CARE PROGRAMS AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES. MISS
BROOKS HAS SERVED IN A NUMBER OF
SENIOR ROLES AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES,
DEVOTING HER CAREER TO
IMPROVEMENT OF HEALTH AND CARE,
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM AND
THE HEALTH CARE AND HEALTH CARE
QUALITY. SHE IS APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON JUNE 12TH ON
A50 VOTE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. I'M SEEING NO
MICROPHONES UP FOR FIVE. ITEM 15
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ALVARADO. GILL. AYE
ARCHULETA I ASHBY. AYE ATKINS I
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER I.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI DODD. AYE
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. AYE HURTADO. AYE. JONES
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN AYE.
MAGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE MIN
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN AYE.
NILA AYE. OCHOA. BORG PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER.
AYE SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DALLI
AYE. OCHOA. BORG. AYE 39. NO.
ZERO. THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. SENATOR GROFF IS
PREPARED. PLEASE BEGIN ON FILE
ITEM 16. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES FILE ITEM
16 IS A CONFIRMATION OF MIKE
MCGUIRE. NO RELATION TO SENATE
PRO TEM OR. EXCUSE ME, SEAN
MCGUIRE. NO RELATIONSHIP TO
SENATOR PRO TEM MIKE MCGUIRE FOR
THE APPOINTMENT OF STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD. HE
FIRST JOINED THE BOARD IN 2018
AND SERVES IN THE SLOT AS
ENGINEER, EXPERIENCED WITH
SANITARY ENGINEER AND WATER
QUALITY. HE WAS APPROVED AT THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON JUNE 12TH AT
A50 VOTE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE, SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLEY. DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO. AYE
JONES. AYE. LAIRD. AYE LIMON.
AYE. MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE.
MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
AYE. NEILA. AYE. OCHOA BOG.
PADILLA. AYE PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE CIERTO.
AYE. SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE.
WILK. AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DALLI AYE.
GROVE. AYE. OCHOA. BOG. AYES 39.
NÓ ZERO. THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. SENATOR GROVE, YOUR
LAST ITEM FILED. FILE ITEM 17.
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU. MADAM
PRESIDENT. FILE ITEM 17.
COLLEAGUES, IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF HARJINDER SHERGILL CHEEMA TO
THE APPOINTMENT OF THE DIRECTOR
OF CALIFORNIA STATE LOTTERY
PRIOR TO HIS ROLE. PRIOR TO THIS
ROLE, HE'D BEEN SERVING AS THE
LOTTERY'S CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
SINCE 2019. HE WAS CONFIRMED ON
A UNANIMOUS VOTE WITH THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JULY OR EXCUSE ME,
JUNE 19TH, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE? SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE DALY. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE
MENGIBAR AYE. MEN I NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN NILA. AYE. OCHOA PADILLA.
AYE PORTANTINO AYE. RATH. AYE
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER.
EYES. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DALLI. AYE GROVE. AYE WHEN? AYE.
Ó BORG. AYE. IS 39. NØ ZERO.
THE CONFIRMATION IS APPROVED. A
SENATOR GROVE FOR WHAT PURPOSE
DO YOU RISE? JUST MY DEEPEST
APOLOGIES, MISS HARJINDER IS A
FEMALE, NOT A MALE. AND I
REFERENCED THE GENDER
INCORRECTLY, AND I APOLOGIZE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR GROVE.
SENATORS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. WE HAVE
THREE ITEMS, 136, 144 AND 165.
BUT WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
FILE ITEM 144. SENATOR GLAZER IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 2813 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND AQUILA
INTO GOVERNMENT FINANCE AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
GLAZER. MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS,
THIS BILL IS A COMPANION MEASURE
TO ACA TI¾N, WHICH THIS BODY
PASSED JUST LAST WEEK. IT
FURTHER DEFINES THE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND REPORTING
PROVISIONS IN ACA ONE AND ADDS
MORE GUARDRAILS BY PROHIBITING
THE ACQUISITION OF EXISTING
HOUSING WITH ACA ONE FUNDS. THIS
BILL WILL ONLY BECOME OPERATIVE
IF ACA ONE IS APPROVED BY VOTERS
IN NOVEMBER. IT BUILDS UPON OUR
EFFORTS TO INCREASE OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY UNDER ACA
ONE. IT'S A PITCH FOR GOOD
GOVERNANCE AND RESPONSIBLE
FISCAL POLICY. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY. I'M SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. THIS IS THIS HAS THE
URGENCY CLAUSE. IT NEEDS 27
VOTES. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN I ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA. I ASHBY I
ATKINS I BECKER. AYE. BLAKE
SPEER I BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ I DALY.
NÓ. DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER I. GONZALEZ.
AYE GROVE. NO. HURTADO AYE.
JONES. NO. LAIRD AYE. LEHMAN
AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE MENGIBAR. AYE.
MIN. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NO.
NILO NO. OCHOA PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE SECRETO. NO. SKINNER.
AYE SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. NO
PLEASE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO. GILL. I DON'T
KNOW MEN. AYE. OCHOA. ON THE
URGENCY. AYES 31. NOS. A MEASURE
PASSES NOW. MOVING BACK TO FILE
ITEM 136. SENATOR SKINNER IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 2157 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA. AN ACT RELATING TO
LOCAL FINANCE AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THEREOF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR SKINNER,
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, I AM PRESENTING AB 2157
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA. IT IS A DISTRICT BILL
THAT WILL ALLOW THE CITY OF
ALAMEDA HEALTH CARE DISTRICT TO
SECURE FINANCING FOR THE SEISMIC
SAFETY WORK THAT IS REQUIRED AT
ALAMEDA HOSPITAL, AND ALAMEDA
HOSPITAL IS THE ONLY HOSPITAL IN
THE CITY OF ALAMEDA, WHICH IS AN
ISLAND, AND IT IS LICENSED AS A
GENERAL ACUTE CARE HOSPITAL. ANY
TEMPORARY CLOSURE OF THAT
HOSPITAL OR REDUCTION OF SERVICE
CAN BE DEVASTATING TO THE
RESIDENTS OF THE ISLAND OF
ALAMEDA. 2157 PROVIDES AN AVENUE
FOR THE DISTRICT TO OBTAIN A
LOWER INTEREST LOAN FOR THE
HOSPITAL TO MEET THE 2030
EARTHQUAKE STANDARDS. THE BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE, AS WELL AS
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO THE
ASSEMBLY IF IT PASSES. THANK YOU
SENATOR. THIS ITEM ALSO HAS A
URGENCY CLAUSE. I SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEAR. AYE
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLY AYE. DODD.
AYE. DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE.
LAIRD AYE. LIMON. AYE MCGUIRE.
AYE. MENGIBAR I MEAN AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NHIÀU
AYE. OCHOA. BOG AYE. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO ACIERTO AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
PORTANTINO. AYE THAT'S 40 TO 0
ON THE URGENCY, 40 TO 0 ON THE
MEASURE. MEMBERS WERE NEXT.
TURNING TO FILE ITEM 165. IT'S
THIS ACR 126 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATERSON. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
126 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOE
PATERSON, RELATIVE TO THE
SERGEANT NICOLE GEE, UNITED
STATES MARINE CORPS MEMORIAL
HIGHWAY. SENATOR NEELO
PRESENTING FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
PATTERSON, SIR. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT,
MEMBERS. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE TWO, SIX HONORS
THE LIFE AND MEMORY OF SERGEANT
NICOLE G. A CONSTITUENT OF MINE
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER. PATTERSON'S
FROM ROSEVILLE AND THIS THIS IS
BEING DONE BY DESIGNATING A
PORTION OF CALIFORNIA INTERSTATE
80 AS THE UNITED STATES MARINE
CORPS. SERGEANT NICOLE GEE
MEMORIAL HIGHWAY. NOW THE TERM
ROCK STAR IS USED TO DESCRIBE A
PERSON OF PARTICULAR CHARACTER,
PASSION FOR LIFE, AND
ACCOMPLISHMENTS. NICOLE G. WAS
VERY YOUNG, BUT SHE WAS A ROCK
STAR. AFTER GRADUATING FROM
OAKMONT HIGH SCHOOL IN ROSEVILLE
IN 2016, NICOLE ENLISTED IN THE
MARINE CORPS IN 2017, SHE WAS
DEPLOYED TO AFGHANISTAN, WHERE
SHE FACILITATED EVACUATION
SUPPORT FOR AFGHAN WOMEN AND
CHILDREN. I NEED TO READ. IF YOU
WILL, SOME OF HER MILITARY
AWARDS AND ACCOMPLISHMENTS. KEEP
IN MIND, THIS WAS A VERY YOUNG
LADY. HER MILITARY AWARDS AND
ACCOMPLISHMENTS INCLUDE THE
PURPLE HEART COMBAT ACTION
RIBBON, MARINE CORPS GOOD
CONDUCT MEDAL, NATIONAL DEFENSE
SERVICE MEDAL, AFGHANISTAN
CAMPAIGN MEDAL, GLOBAL WAR ON
TERRORISM SERVICE MEDAL, SEA
SERVICE DEPLOYMENT RIBBON, NATO
MEDAL, EXPERT RIFE RIFLE
QUALIFICATION, THIRD AWARD,
BECOMING A BLACK BELT MARTIAL
ARTS INSTRUCTOR, SETTING
WEIGHTLIFTING RECORDS AT AHMAD
AL-JABER AIR BASE AND ACHIEVING
PERFECT SCORES IN COMBAT FITNESS
TESTS. UNFORTUNATELY, IN AUGUST
OF 2021, NICOLE TRAGICALLY LOST
HER LIFE IN A SUICIDE ATTACK
ALONG WITH 12 OTHER SERVICE
MEMBERS. JUST THREE WEEKS BEFORE
HER DEATH. SHE HAD BEEN PROMOTED
TO SERGEANT DUE TO HER OBVIOUS
OUTSTANDING WORK. LESS THAN A
WEEK PRIOR TO THE ATTACK, NICOLE
MADE A SOCIAL MEDIA POST HOLDING
AND CARING FOR AN AFGHAN INFANT.
I LOVE MY JOB. NICOLE'S ACTIONS,
ALONG WITH THOSE OF OTHER
SERVICEMEN AND WOMEN INVOLVED IN
SCREENING FEMALE EVACUEES, SAVED
OVER 124,000 LIVES DURING
AMERICA'S LARGEST AIRLIFT
OPERATION. WE HOLD A SPECIAL
PLACE IN OUR HEARTS FOR NICOLE,
REMEMBERING THE JOY SHE BROUGHT
TO EVERYONE SHE KNEW AND THE
LIGHT SHE WAS TO OTHERS
WORLDWIDE, MY FRIEND AND
COLLEAGUE, ASSEMBLYMAN PATTERSON
, MADE THIS PRESENTATION ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR A WEEK OR TWO
AGO, AND HER WHOLE FAMILY WAS
THERE TO WITNESS IT. IT WAS
QUITE MOVING, ESPECIALLY BECAUSE
THEY WERE THERE. HER LEGACY WILL
LIVE ON, INSPIRING US TO CHERISH
THE LIBERTIES WE ENJOY TODAY.
MAY WE ALWAYS REMEMBER THE
SACRIFICES OF OUR MILITARY
MEMBERS AND THEIR FAMILIES THAT
THEY MAKE FOR OUR FREEDOM. I ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON ACR 126.
THANK YOU SENATOR. SENATOR
NELLIS, SENATOR MENGIBAR, PLEASE
GIVE HER ATTENTION. MEMBERS.
THANK YOU, MISTER PRESIDENT. I
DO ASK IF WE COULD TAKE
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR. IF
YOU DIDN'T KNOW, THE MARINE
CORPS HAS THE SMALLEST
PERCENTAGE OF WOMEN COMPARED TO
EVERY OTHER BRANCH. THERE ARE
ONLY 10% OF WOMEN WHO JOIN THE
MARINE CORPS. THE MOTTO IN THE
MARINE CORPS IS THE FEW. THE
PROUD WOMEN. WE SAY, THE FEWER
THE PROUDER, BECAUSE NOT A LOT
OF US JOIN. THERE'S A GROUP OF
FACEBOOK GROUP OF FEMALE MARINES
AS OLD AS 80 TO AS YOUNG AS 18
YEARS OLD, AND WE SHARE ALL OUR
EXPERIENCES ON THIS FACEBOOK
GROUP, REGARDLESS OF WE MET IN
PERSON OR NOT, PROBABLY A COUPLE
OF DAYS BEFORE SERGEANT G PASSED
AWAY, THEY POSTED A PHOTO OF
HER, ESCORTING, INDIVIDUALS FROM
KABUL AIRPORT. AND IN THAT
PHOTO, THEY HAD HER, THEY POSTED
IT. AND UNFORTUNATELY, THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE PLACED ON
THERE WEREN'T POSITIVE. IT WAS
JUST AN EXAMPLE OF SOME OF THE
TREATMENT. THE OBJECTIFICATION
OF WOMEN IN THE MILITARY. AND
THIS WAS JUST DAYS BEFORE SHE
PASSED AWAY. AND THEN WE FOUND
OUT THAT SHE PASSED AWAY. AND IN
A COUPLE OF DAYS IT WENT FROM
OBJECTIFICATION TO SHE'S A HERO
AND SO FORTH. AS A FEMALE
SERVICE MEMBER, THAT CHANGE
ALWAYS HAPPENS. IT'S CONSTANTLY
THERE. AND IT WAS EVEN MORE
FRUSTRATING FOR US FEMALE
MARINES WHEN WE SAW THAT,
BECAUSE WE KNOW WHAT THAT FELT
LIKE. THIS GROUP WE CREATED A
GOFUNDME PAGE AND WE CONTRIBUTED
TO THIS FUND TO GET ALL HER
FAMILY MEMBERS FROM ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES TO BE ABLE TO
ATTEND HER FUNERAL. THE DEATH OF
2424 YEAR OLD SERGEANT NICOLE G.
REALLY HIT ME AT HOME BECAUSE
SHE WAS FROM CALIFORNIA. I'M SO
THANKFUL FOR THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TO ACKNOWLEDGE OUR FALLEN HERO
THAT ALONG ON MY WAY TO
PLACERVILLE TO ONE OF MY
FAVORITE LAKES, I WILL SEE HER
NAME MEMORIALIZED IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE SHE WAS A
HERO AND SHE WAS SO YOUNG WHEN
SHE WAS TAKEN. YOU HEARD HER
LAST POST OF I LOVE MY JOB. SHE
HAD FOUR YEARS IN THE MARINE
CORPS. AND THAT'S THE FEELING WE
ALL HAVE WHEN WE PUT ON THAT
UNIFORM. WHEN THEY PASSED AWAY,
HER AND THE 12 OTHER SERVICE
MEMBERS, MY DISTRICT WILL.
BEFORE I WAS A SENATOR, WE HELD
A SPECIAL HORSE MEMORIAL RIDE
WHERE 13 OF US DID A HORSE RIDE
WITH AMERICAN FLAGS DRAPED OVER
THE HORSES FOR EVERY SINGLE
SERVICE MEMBER THAT PASSED AWAY,
BECAUSE IT WAS LITERALLY THE
LAST DAY WE WERE ENDING THE WAR,
THEY HAD PLANS MADE AND THE
STORY IS THAT HER HER VEHICLE
WAS IN THE PARKING LOT OF THE
BARRACKS, AND I SAW MY FELLOW
MARINE SISTERS SHARE POSTS ON
FACEBOOK OF THE CAR IS STILL
THERE IN THE PARKING LOT, BUT
SHE WOULD NEVER COME BACK. THERE
WAS ANOTHER FEMALE MARINE THAT
PERISHED IN THAT, IN THAT
TRAGEDY AS WELL. TWO OUT OF THE
13. SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS UP. AND I PULLED
IT FROM CONSENT BECAUSE I
THOUGHT MY SISTER IN ARMS
DESERVED TO HAVE HER STORY TOLD
ON THE SENATE FLOOR,
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR AN I
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
MENGIBAR. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS RESOLUTION?
SEEING NONE, IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING NO
OBJECTIONS. EXCUSE ME, SENATOR
NILO, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
YES. I'D JUST LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT MY FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE
FROM ROCKLIN, ASSEMBLYMAN
PATTERSON, IS HERE WITH ME. AS I
WAS WITH HIM THE OTHER DAY. AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR NILO.
ASSEMBLYMAN, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US ON OUR FLOOR. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. MEMBERS AYES 40 NOES
ZERO. THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MOVING ON TO OUR FINAL ITEM ON
ASSEMBLY. WELL, NO, WE JUST
FINISHED ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
WE ARE NOW ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. WE HAVE ITEMS 182
THROUGH 194. WOULD ANYONE LIKE
TO POST SOMETHING? SENATOR DODD?
THANK YOU, MADAM PRO TEM AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR, PLEASE
REMOVE AB 1505. THIS IS. AM I IN
THE WRONG SPOT HERE? THIS IS
OKAY. YOU CAN DO IT. YES. GO
AHEAD. THAT WOULD BE AS YOU
WERE, SENATOR. AFTER WE ASK FOR
THE AUTHOR, PLEASE REMOVE AB
1505, WHICH IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
184 FROM THE FIRST DAY CONSENT
CALENDAR. THE DEATHS WERE NO SEN
WIENER. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT, AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR, PLEASE REMOVE AB 2867
FILE ITEM EIGHT FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THE DEATH IS NOTED.
AND THEN IN ADDITION, I'D LIKE
TO ASK THAT AB 1465 FILE ITEM
A11 BE REMOVED FROM INACTIVE AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR. THE
DEATH IS NOTED. I SEE NOTHING
FURTHER. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
CONSENT CALENDAR ASSEMBLY BILL
1854 1982 2521. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
FIRST ITEM. ALLEN ALVARADO GIL,
A ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY I
DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLASER
I GONZALEZ I GROVE I HURTADO I
JONES I LAIRD I LIMON I MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR I MEN, I NEWMAN I
NGUYEN I NILO I OCHOA BOGH I
PADILLA I PORTANTINO RATH I
RUBIO I SUGIARTO I SKINNER I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I STERN I
UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK I
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN I MCGUIRE I. PORTANTINO I
AYES 40 NO. ZERO CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED. WE ARE
MOVING BACK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS SEN NEWMAN UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. SEN.
NEWMAN. YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I
MOVE TO SUSPEND JOINT RULE 10.5
AS IT RELATES TO ASSEMBLY BILL
247. THE DESK IS NOTED. SENATOR
JONES, PRESIDENT. THIS BILL IS
TAGGED FISCAL BY A LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL AND COULD AUTHORIZE UP
TO $10 BILLION IN SPENDING AND
SHOULD BE ABSOLUTELY HEARD IN
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. AS
THE VICE CHAIR OF
APPROPRIATIONS, I WOULD ASK FOR
IT TO GO TO APPROPRIATIONS
MOTION. SENATOR, THIS MOTION IS
NOT DEBATABLE. SENATOR JONES IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. SENATOR
NEWMAN IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN, I. ALVARADO. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA. I ASHBY I
ATKINS, I BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER I BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO
I CORTEZ I DALLEY. NØ DODD I
DURAZZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE. NO HURTADO I
JONES. NO. LAIRD I LIMÓN I
MCGUIRE I MENGIBAR I MIN I
NEWMAN I NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO.
OCHOA. BOGH NO. PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I RATH I RUBIO I SATO
. NO. SKINNER I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB
I WIENER I WILK. NO AYES 32 NOES
A MOTION PASSES. JOINT RULES ARE
SUSPENDED. MAJORITY LEADER,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS, I MOVE JOINT RULE 62 A
TO BE WAIVED FOR THE FOLLOWING
COMMITTEES TO MEET AND HEAR
BILLS AND SUBJECT MATTER WITHOUT
SUFFICIENT NOTICE IN THE SENATE
DAILY FILE ONE. ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS
COMMITTEE TO HEAR AB 1440 TODAY,
JULY FIRST, 2024. TWO NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER AND
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEES
TO MEET FOR AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON JULY 2ND, 2024 THREE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TIME CHANGE
FROM 9:30 A.M. TO 8 A.M. ON JULY
2ND, 2024, AND FOR ALL
COMMITTEES CURRENTLY NOTICE IN
THE SENATE DAILY FILE FOR
WEDNESDAY, JULY 3RD, 2024 WILL
BEGIN AT 9 A.M. SENATOR JONES,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. MADAM
PRESIDENT, WE'VE BEEN IN SESSION
NOW FOR SIX MONTHS AND WE'VE HAD
PLENTY OF TIME TO PROCESS THESE
TYPES OF BILLS OVER THE YEARS.
THERE'S NO REASON THAT THESE
BILLS WERE DUMPED IN OUR LAP AT
THE LAST MINUTE AND ASKING FOR
DEBATE AND FOR DEBATE TO BE HELD
IN SUSPENDED FOR THESE
AMENDMENTS AND TO BE HEARD.
SENATOR, THIS ITEM IS ALSO NOT
THIS MOTION IS ALSO NOT
DEBATABLE. I UNDERSTAND THAT,
BUT WE HAVE PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO THIS MOTION
RULES IN THIS HOUSE IS NOT
DEBATABLE, AND I'M ASKING THAT
WE HAVE A NO VOTE ON THIS MOTION
AND THAT THE BODY SENATOR JONES
IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE.
MAJORITY LEADER IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO UTILIZING THE PREVIOUSLY ROLL
CALL? WE'RE ASKING FOR A ROLL
CALL. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ALVARADO GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS,
I BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER I
BRADFORD. CABALLERO I CORTEZ I
DALLEY. NØ. DODD I DURAZZO I
EGGMAN I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE. NO. HURTADO I JONES NO.
LAIRD I LIMÓN I MCGUIRE I
MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN I NGUYEN
. NO. NILO. NO. OCHOA NO.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO, I CIERTO. NO. SKINNER I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I STERN, I
UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK.
NO. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BRADFORD I AYES 32 NOES.
AYE. MOTION CARRIES. JOINT RULES
ARE SUSPENDED. SENATOR
BLAKESBERG, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU. MEMBERS, I MOVE TO
SUSPEND JOINT RULE 10.5 AS IT
RELATES TO ASSEMBLY BILL 440.
SENATOR JONES, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. ASSEMBLY BILL 440 HAS
BEEN TAGGED FISCAL BY THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST. I'D ASK FOR
A NO VOTE ON THIS MOTION.
SENATOR JONES IS ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE. SENATOR BLAKESBERG IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANY
OBJECTION TO UTILIZING THE
PREVIOUS ROLL EYES? 32 NOES,
EIGHT MOTION PASSES. JOINT RULES
ARE SUSPENDED. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION, ASSEMBLY BILL 1272
WILL BE RETURNED TO THE ASSEMBLY
. WITHOUT OBJECTION, THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR JUNE 24TH, 2024
THROUGH JUNE 27TH, 2024 WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. NO FURTHER ITEMS
UNDER MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. WE ARE MOVING BACK TO
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS,
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS. SENATOR
BREAKSPEARE THANK YOU. ELECTIONS
AND CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS
COMMITTEE SHALL MEET UPON
ADJOURNMENT IN ROOM 1200. THANK
YOU, SENATOR ALVARADO HILL,
SENATE COMMITTEE ON HUMAN
SERVICES WILL MEET UPON
ADJOURNMENT IN ROOM 2200. AND WE
HAVE PING PONG BACK TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS. THIS IS THE
TIME FOR ADJOURN. IN MEMORIES,
WE HAVE THREE ADJOURN IN
MEMORIES. SENATORS, THIS IS A
TIME TO LISTEN TO OUR COLLEAGUES
AS THEY WILL HONOR LOVED ONES.
SENATOR DURAZZO, YOU ARE FIRST.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, IT IS WITH PRIDE
THAT I ASK. WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF NBA LEGEND MR. JERRY
WEST. THE STORY OF THE NBA WOULD
NOT HAVE EXISTED WITHOUT MR.
WEST. GRACE AND PASSIONATE
PRESENCE HELPING GUIDE THE MAJOR
ERAS OF THE SPORT. HIS
BASKETBALL JOURNEY BEGAN IN
HUMBLE BEGINNINGS. GROWING UP IN
WEST VIRGINIA IN THE 1950S,
WHERE HIS LOVE FOR THE GAME
DROVE HIM TO CONSTANTLY PRACTICE
WITH THE MAKESHIFT HOOP NAILED
TO A STORAGE SHED. HE WAS A STAR
AT EAST BANK HIGH SCHOOL,
LEADING HIS TEAM TO THE 1956
STATE CHAMPIONSHIP AND BECOMING
ONE OF THE BEST WEST VIRGINIA
HIGH SCHOOL PLAYERS OF HIS
GENERATION, WITH SEVERAL
ALL-STATE, ALL-AMERICAN, AND
STATE PLAYER OF THE YEAR HONORS,
WEST MID-RANGE JUMP SHOT BECAME
HIS TRADEMARK, AND HE OFTEN USED
IT TO SCORE WHILE UNDER PRESSURE
FROM OPPOSING DEFENSES. AS ONE
OF THE GAME'S FIRST LOCKDOWN
SHOOTERS AFTER HIGH SCHOOL, HE
STAYED LOCAL AND ATTENDED WEST
VIRGINIA UNIVERSITY, WHERE HIS
HIS PROLIFIC SCORING PROFILE
TRANSITION SEAMLESSLY TO THE
COLLEGE RANKS. COLLEGIATE RANKS
AGAIN, EARNING SEVERAL
ALL-AMERICAN FIRST TEAM, ALL
SOUTHERN CONFERENCE AND
TOURNAMENT MVP HONORS. AS OF
2011, HE STILL HELD 2012 WVU ALL
TIME RECORDS. AFTER HIS JUNIOR
YEAR, MR. WEST WAS NAMED TO THE
US PAN AMERICAN GAMES BASKETBALL
TEAM, HELPING THE TEAM WIN THE
GOLD MEDAL. HE ALSO CO-CAPTAINED
CAPTAINED THE 1960S U.S. MEN'S
BASKETBALL OLYMPIC GOLD WINNING
TEAM WITH OSCAR ROBERTSON. HIS
PROLIFIC COLLEGE CAREER LED MR.
WEST TO BEING SELECTED SECOND
OVERALL BY THE THEN MINNEAPOLIS
LAKERS IN 1960, WHERE HE SERVED
A PIVOTAL ROLE WHEN THE
FRANCHISE RELOCATED TO LOS
ANGELES SHORTLY THEREAFTER.
BEFORE THE 1960 61 SEASON.
TEAMING UP WITH FELLOW LAKER
GREATS ELGIN BAYLOR AND WILT
CHAMBERLAIN. ONE OF THE FIRST LÀ
SPORTS SUPERSTARS, HE BECAME
KNOWN AS MR. CLUTCH. HE SHINED
IN THE BRIGHTEST IN THE
POSTSEASON, LEADING THE PLAYOFF
IN SCORING FOUR TIMES, INCLUDING
WHEN HE AVERAGED 40 POINTS IN
1965 FOR 14 TIME. ALL STAR, 12
TIME ALL-NBA SELECTION, AND
HELPED LEAD THE LAKERS TO NINE
NBA FINALS AND RECOGNIZED AS THE
ONLY PLAYER IN NBA HISTORY TO
WIN THE MVP FOR THE LOSING TEAM
IN THE CHAMPIONSHIP SERIES IN
1969, WINNING THE TITLE IN 1972
BEFORE HE RETIRED IN 74. HIS
PLAYING CAREER HIGHLIGHTS EARNED
MR. WEST HIS SECOND ELECTION TO
THE BASKETBALL HALL OF FAME IN
1980, AS WELL AS SELECTIONS TO
THE NBA 35TH ANNIVERSARY TEAM,
ONE OF THE 50 GREATEST PLAYERS
IN NBA HISTORY. IN 1996, HE ALSO
HIS SILHOUETTE ALSO SERVED AS
THE BASIS FOR THE NBA LOGO
ADOPTED IN 1969. POST-PLAYING
CAREER. MR. WEST SERVED AS A
LAKERS COACH FOR THREE SEASONS
BEFORE TRANSITIONING TO WHAT
WOULD BECOME ONE OF THE MOST
INFLUENTIAL EXECUTIVE CAREERS IN
THE LEAGUE'S STORIED HISTORY. HE
WAS GENERAL MANAGER FROM 79 TO
2000, AND IN THAT TIME HE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN THE BUILDING OF
SOME OF THE MOST DOMINANT ERAS
OF LAKERS BASKETBALL. HE HELPED
BUILD THE FIVE TIME CHAMPION
1980S SHOWTIME LAKERS WITH
GREATS LIKE MAGIC JOHNSON, JAMES
WORTHY, KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR AND
COACH RILEY. HIS EYE FOR TALENT
HELPED HIM IDENTIFY THE STARS
FOR THE PURPLE AND GOLD WHEN HE
SIGNED ALL STAR CENTER SHAQUILLE
O'NEAL TO PAIR WITH A YOUNG KOBE
BRYANT FOR A STRONG LAKERS TEAM
COACHED BY THE ZEN MASTER PHIL
JACKSON. DESPITE MR. WEST HAVING
DEPARTED AT THE END OF THE 99
2000 SEASON AFTER WINNING HIS
SIXTH CHAMPIONSHIP AS A LAKERS
EXECUTIVE, HE LAID THE
FOUNDATION OF THIS NEXT DOMINANT
LAKERS DOMINANT RUN WITH THE
2000 2002 THREE PEAT. AFTER A
BRIEF STINT WITH THE MEMPHIS
GRIZZLIES AND RETIREMENT, MR.
WEST COULD NOT LEAVE FOR LONG.
WHEN HE WAS ASKED TO JOIN THE
GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS EXECUTIVE
BOARD. DURING HIS TIME IN THE
BAY AREA, HIS BASKETBALL GENIUS
CONTRIBUTED TO DRAFTING THE BEST
SHOOTING BACKCOURT EVER. STEPHEN
CURRY AND KLAY THOMPSON, TO PAIR
WITH OTHER STARS DRAYMOND GREEN
AND KEVIN DURANT FOR THE
INCREDIBLE WARRIORS TEAM. A
RECENT MEMORY THAT CAPTURED FOUR
TITLES, WITH MR. WEST WINNING
HIS SEVENTH AND EIGHTH TITLES AS
AN EXECUTIVE. LEADING UP TO HIS
PASSING, MR. WEST WAS SHARING
HIS INSIGHT IN A CONSULTANT ROLE
FOR THE NEW ERA LOS ANGELES
CLIPPERS. HE WILL BE INDICTED IN
THE NAISMITH MEMORIAL BASKETBALL
HALL OF FAME FOR A THIRD TIME
FOR HIS WORK AS AN EXECUTIVE,
MAKING HIM THE FIRST TO BE
ELECTED AS A PLAYER AND AN
EXECUTIVE. HE WAS ALSO AWARDED
THE PRESIDENTIAL MEDAL OF
FREEDOM IN 2019. DESPITE ALL OF
HIS SUCCESS, A HUMBLE AND
CENTERED FIGURE, HE WAS NEVER
ONE FOR THE SPOTLIGHT. HIS
GREATNESS BROUGHT. HE WAS NEVER
KNOWN TO. HE WAS KNOWN TO NEVER
WANT TO WATCH THE GAMES
PUBLICLY. I MENTION ALL OF THE
SUCCESS THAT HE HAS CONTRIBUTED
BECAUSE I BELIEVE MR. WEST WOULD
HAVE WANTED TO SHARE IN HIS
SUCCESS WITH HIS FELLOW PLAYER
COLLEAGUES IN THE LEAGUE,
DESPITE BEING A PROMINENT FIGURE
IN THE GAME'S HISTORY, HE WAS
QUOTED MOST RECENTLY AS WANTING
TO HAVE BEEN REMEMBERED FOR
BEING A NICE GUY, SOMEONE THAT
LOVED THE GAME OF BASKETBALL,
APPRECIATED ALL IT GAVE HIM, AND
HE GAVE IT ALL HE COULD UNTIL
HIS LAST DAYS. HE IS SURVIVED BY
HIS WIDOW, CHRISTINE, FIVE SONS,
DAVID, MARK, MICHAEL, BRIAN AND
JOHNNY, AND EXTENDED COMMUNITY
OF LOVED ONES. THE NBA AND A
LEGION OF BASKETBALL FANS. REST
IN PEACE MR. WEST. THANK YOU
SENATOR. PLEASE BRING MR. WEST'S
NAME FORWARD SO THAT HE MAY BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED IN THE
JOURNAL. SENATOR DODD. MADAM
PRESIDENT, MEMBERS TODAY I'M
HONORED BEYOND BELIEF, FRANKLY,
TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF, IN
MY MIND, THE GREATEST PLAYER OF
ALL TIME, WILLIE MAYS, OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS THE SAY-HEY KID, WHO
PASSED AWAY AT THE AGE OF 93
WITH HIS INCREDIBLE TALENT AND
UNWAVERING DEDICATION AND
BOUNDLESS CHARISMA, MAYS LEFT
HIS MARK ON BASEBALL AND HE
CAPTURED THE HEARTS AND MINDS OF
SO MANY. MAYS BEGAN HIS PLAYING
CAREER IN THE LEAGUES FOR THE
BIRMINGHAM BARONS OF ALABAMA AT
THE YOUNG AGE OF 17. HE WAS
LATER SIGNED TO PLAY BASEBALL
FOR THE THEN NEW YORK GIANTS,
AND LATER SAN FRANCISCO GIANTS.
HE THEN PLAYED 21 SEASONS OF
BASEBALL WHILE ALSO SERVING HIS
COUNTRY IN THE ARMY. IN 1952 AND
1953, AND MAYS WAS MORE THAN A
TYPICAL BALLPLAYER, AS HE WAS
CONSIDERED ONE OF THE BEST DUE
TO HIS ABILITY. DUE TO HIS
ABILITY TO HIT FOR POWER, HIT
FOR AVERAGE, RUN, FIELD THROW
LIKE NO OTHER. HE WAS ALSO KNOWN
FOR HIS SMOOTH BASKET STYLE
CATCHES, WHICH BECAME HIS
SIGNATURE PLAY DURING THE COURSE
OF HIS PLAYING CAREER, HE HIT
660 HOME RUNS AND REMEMBER, HE
WASN'T THERE FOR TWO OF THE
YEARS BECAUSE HE WAS SERVING OUR
COUNTRY. HE WAS NAMED THE MOST
VALUABLE PLAYER TWICE, WINNING
THE ROOKIE OF THE YEAR AWARD AND
WINNING AN ASTOUNDING 12 GOLDEN
GLOVES. WILLIE MAYS WAS AN
AMAZING BASEBALL PLAYER, BUT
EVEN A BETTER INDIVIDUAL,
INSPIRING SO MANY TO PLAY THE
GAME HE LOVED DEARLY. HE
CERTAINLY BROKE BARRIERS AND
INSPIRED COUNTLESS, COUNTLESS
YOUNG ATHLETES, SHOWING THEM
WITH THE TALENT AND PERSEVERANCE
. ANYTHING IS POSSIBLE. HIS
HUMILITY, HIS SPORTSMANSHIP AND
LOVE FOR THE GAME ENDEARED HIM
TO FANS AND FELLOW PLAYERS
ALIKE. HIS CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
SPORT WILL BE CHERISHED FOR
YEARS TO COME. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
ADJOURNING IN THE MEMORY OF THE
LATE, GREAT WILLIE MAYS. SENATOR
BECKER, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. I
THANK YOU. I ALSO RISE ON THIS
ADJOURN IN MEMORY. AS A LIFELONG
BASEBALL FAN, I'M DEEPLY HONORED
TO JOIN IN THIS FOR THE GREAT
WILLIE MAYS, AND I DO MEAN GREAT
TED WILLIAMS SAID THAT THE ALL
STAR GAME WAS INVENTED FOR
WILLIE MAYS, AND PEOPLE WOULD
EXPECT MIRACLES. I SAW A QUOTE
FROM REGGIE JACKSON WHERE HE
SAID, IF WILLIE CAME TO THE BAT
AND THE SCORE WAS FIVE, NOTHING
YOU EXPECTED HIM TO HIT A FIVE
RUN HOME RUN. I'M ALSO PROUD TO
SAY HE WAS A CONSTITUENT OF MINE
FOR THE LAST FOUR DECADES OF HIS
LIFE, HE LIVED IN ATHERTON. A
CONFERENCE ROOM IN THE LIBRARY
IS DEDICATED TO HIM, AND EVERY
HALLOWEEN HE WOULD HANG OUT. HE
WOULD HAND OUT BASEBALLS TO
TRICK OR TREATERS HIMSELF. HE
WAS HONORED AS A HISTORY MAKER
IN THE SAN MATEO COUNTY
HISTORICAL ASSOCIATION, AND THEY
NOTED THAT HE WAS BEING HONORED
FOR USING HIS FAME AS ONE OF THE
GREATEST ATHLETES EVER TO HELP
OTHERS IN CHARITABLE AND
VOLUNTEER ENDEAVORS. MANY DON'T
KNOW ABOUT THIS PART OF HIS
LEGACY. HIS SAY HEY FOUNDATION
IS DEDICATED TO FULFILLING HIS
DREAM OF GIVING EVERY CHILD A
CHANCE BY OFFERING
UNDERPRIVILEGED YOUTH POSITIVE
OPPORTUNITIES AND SAFER
COMMUNITIES. THE FOUNDATION HAS
ASSISTED SCHOOLS, HOMELESS
PROGRAMS, LITTLE LEAGUE TEAMS,
COLLEGE BASEBALL TEAMS,
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAMS, VIOLENCE
PREVENTION PROGRAMS, AND BOYS
AND GIRLS CLUBS. HE WAS A
VOLUNTEER FOR THE SAN MATEO
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT. HE
WOULD PERSONALLY VISIT AND
INSPIRE PRISONERS WITHIN THE
JAIL. YES WILLIE IS ONE OF THE
GREATEST PLAYERS EVER. HE SET
NEW STANDARDS FOR EXCELLENCE. AS
MY COLLEAGUE FROM NAPA
MENTIONED. BUT HE'S ALSO A
LEGEND OFF THE FIELD, USING HIS
GIFTS AS A HUMAN BEING IN
COMMUNITY AS NATURALLY AS HIS
ATHLETIC GIFTS ON THE FIELD. WE
ARE BLESSED TO HAVE HIM WITH US
FOR 93 YEARS, AND I JOIN MY
COLLEAGUE. HOPE YOU ALL JOIN US
IN ADJOURNING THE SENATE IN HIS
MEMORY. SENATOR LARRY, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO JOIN MY
COLLEAGUES IN MEMORY OF WILLIE
MAYS AND FOR THOSE OF US THAT
CAME OF AGE WHEN HE WAS A
PLAYER, HE WAS JUST AN INTEGRAL
PART OF OUR CHILDHOOD. AND I HAD
THE MISFORTUNE SINCE THE GIANTS
AND THE DODGERS CAME TO THE WEST
COAST WHEN I WAS EIGHT TO HAVE
ALREADY COMMITTED TO MY FATHER'S
CHICAGO CUBS. THAT MADE FOR A
VERY DIFFICULT TIME ATTENDING
GAMES IN SAN FRANCISCO AND YET
MY DAD TOOK ME TO SEE WILLIE
MAYS IN SEALS STADIUM. HE TOOK
ME TO SEE HIM IN CANDLESTICK
PARK AND FOR CUBS FAN, YOU MIGHT
BE AHEAD IN PART OF THE GAME AND
YOU KNEW THAT THE ANNOUNCER
WOULD INTONE THE BATTER, NUMBER
24, WILLIE MAYS AND OUR GOOSE
WAS COOKED. IT GENERALLY MEANT
THAT THE GAME WOULD TURN, BUT
THERE WAS ONE TIME I GOT TO BE
ON THE SAME SIDE, AND THE
SENATOR FROM SAN MATEO MENTIONED
HIS ALL STAR GAMES, WHILE MY DAD
AND HIS BEST FRIEND AND HIS SON,
MY BEST FRIEND, SCORED FOUR
TICKETS TO THE 1961 ALL STAR
GAME AT CANDLESTICK PARK. THIS
IS WHERE CANDLESTICK WAS BEING
SHOWN OFF TO THE REST OF THE
NATION AS A BRAND NEW PARK. AND
IT'S THE GAME THAT WAS KNOWN
BECAUSE RELIEVER STU MILLER WAS
SUPPOSEDLY BLOWN OFF THE MOUND
IN THE WINDS OF THE LATE INNINGS
THAT AT CANDLESTICK PARK AND THE
GREAT THING WAS, IS THERE WERE
TWO PLAYERS THAT DAY THAT HAD
FIVE AT BATS FOR THE NATIONAL
LEAGUE. MAURY WILLS FROM THE
SENATOR FROM LOS ANGELES. HIS
HOMETOWN TEAM, AND WILLIE MAYS.
AND IT WAS A ONE RUN GAME AND
WILLIE MAYS KNOCKED A RUN IN AND
SCORED A RUN, AND ARGUABLY MADE
THE DIFFERENCE IN THE OUTCOME OF
THAT GAME. AND THAT'S JUST WHO
HE WAS. HE WAS EVERYTHING ELSE
THAT WAS SAID AS A GENTLEMAN, A
COMMUNITY MEMBER, AN
UNBELIEVABLE PERSON. BUT IT WAS
JUST ONE OF THE BEST BASEBALL
PLAYERS. AND IF YOU WERE GOING
TO A GAME WHERE HE PLAYED, YOU
WERE NEVER DISAPPOINTED. THANK
YOU. SENATOR LAIRD. SENATOR
DODD, PLEASE BRING YOUR SPORTS
HEROES NAME FORWARD SO THAT WE
MAY PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE HIM.
OUR LAST AIM OF THE DAY IS GOING
TO BE SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE, TODAY I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
DANIEL, OTHERWISE KNOWN AS DAN
SPADARO, A RESIDENT OF ROSEMEAD
WHO PASSED AWAY AT THE AGE OF
90, SURROUNDED BY FAMILY TO THE
CHILDREN OF ROSEMEAD AND ALL
OVER THE SEYARTO VALLEY, DAN AND
HIS FAMILY BROUGHT SO MUCH JOY
DURING THE HOLIDAY SEASONS,
ESPECIALLY THE DECEMBER
FESTIVITIES WERE ESTABLISHED.
BECAUSE OF HIM, HE WOULD HAVE A
TRADITION WHERE HE WOULD
DECORATE A CASTLE SO AS KNOWN AS
CHRISTMAS CASTLE FOR OVER 50
YEARS, DAN DECORATED CHRISTMAS
CASTLE WITH DIFFERENT THEMES.
ONE YEAR IT WAS THE OLD WOMAN
WHO LIVED IN A SHOE. ANOTHER
YEAR FOCUSING ON THE MERRY GO
ROUND, BRINGING JOY AND
EXCITEMENT TO THE COMMUNITY.
WHEN HE STARTED HIS TRADITION,
DAN WAS A TRUCK DRIVER FOR
MATTEL. HE WAS ABLE TO GATHER
ALL THE EXTRA TOYS THAT WERE
LEFT AND SHARE THEM WITH THE
CHILDREN WHO NEEDED IT THE MOST.
HE WAS KNOWN TO SOME AS SANTA
FOR THE CITY OF ROSEMEAD. DAN
CARED DEEPLY FOR HIS COMMUNITY,
AND IN RETURN THE COMMUNITY CAME
TOGETHER AND DECORATED HIS HOME
WHEN HE COULD NO LONGER
PHYSICALLY DO SO HIMSELF. AFTER
HIS WIFE, MRS. MARIE SPADARO,
PASSED AWAY, THE ROSEMEAD
BEAUTIFICATION COMMITTEE CREATED
A HOLIDAY DECORATING CONTEST,
AND THE GRAND PRIZE WINNER WOULD
RECEIVE THE MARY SPADARO
CHRISTMAS CASTLE AWARD. THIS
YEAR, THE CITY OF ROSEMEAD WILL
BE GIVING OUT AGAIN THE SAME
RECOGNITION, EXCEPT THAT NOW IT
WAS NAMED DAN AND MARIE SPADARO
CHRISTMAS CASTLE AWARD TO HONOR
BOTH OF THEM. THAT DID SO MUCH
FOR ROSEMEAD AND SO MANY
FAMILIES THAT NEEDED TOYS DURING
THE HOLIDAY SEASON. PLEASE JOIN
ME IN ADJOURNING IN MEMORY OF
DAN SPADARO. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU SENATOR. PLEASE BRING DAN'S
NAME FORWARD SO THAT HE MAY BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. IF THERE
IS NO OTHER BUSINESS. SENATOR
GROVE, THE DESK IS CLEAR, THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, SADLY. WEDNESDAY,
JULY 3RD, 2024, IS SCHEDULED FOR
SESSION. THE NEXT SCHEDULED
FLOOR SESSION WILL GO VERY LATE
AT NIGHT. FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND. AND IT'S UPON THE
CALL OF THE SENATE PRO TEM. THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
3:30 P.M, AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE.
WE WILL RECONVENE WEDNESDAY,
JULY 3RD, UPON THE CALL OF THE
PRESIDENT PRO TEM. MAY THE ODDS
BE EVER IN YOUR FAVOR.